Now that our Java joke telling
code is really coming along,
we've broken it out
into its own library.
That way we can reuse
it across projects.
Let's check out how this project works.
Inside our Android app build directory,
we have this javaJokes directory that
contains a stock Gradle Java project,
just like we've been building all along.
If we use the terminal to navigate to
the javaJokes directory, we can use
Gradle to build this project on its own,
without reference to the Android app.
However, our app doesn't yet
know anything about this library.
What we need to do is
declare a compile dependency
on the output of this library project.
To do that,
we need to add the library project
to the same multi-project
build as our Android app.
We can do that in the settings.gradle
file of the root project.
The settings.gradle file is where we
tell Gradle what sub-projects to include
in the multi-project build.
We already have the app project for
the Android app, so
we'll add the javaJokes project.
There we go.
Now if we ask Gradle what projects or
sub-projects in this multi-project
build, Gradle tells us that there are
two sub-projects, the Android app and
the Java library.
Next we need to declare a project
dependency between our Android app and
our Java library.
We can do that in the build.gradle
file in the app directory.
Here we simply say that our app
has a compile time dependency
on the project javaJokes.
Now that we've gone ahead and declared
that dependency, we can go ahead and
import our Java library into
our Android project, and
we can use the class
from our Java library.
If we bust out the old test device,
here's the joke from our Java
library inside our Android app.
When you run this multi-project build,
if you watch the Gradle console
you'll notice something like this.
The app project started
running some tasks.
Then the javaJokes project jumped in to
create a jar for the app project to use.
Well, that's all there is to it,
to add a Java library project
to an Android studio build.